- So I'm lost.
Hope you have an amazing weekend.
(upbeat music)
Good morning everybody, I
had a early sleep last night
and then an early morning this morning.
I'm feeling great.
Another beautiful, sunny
day here in Palm Springs.
Pretty productive morning,
started off by messaging Nina.
You got to message the wife first thing,
it's important guys, message
your wife when you go away.
Then worked on an exciting
thing that I'm planning
for my YouTube channel.
Two exciting things, so we'll see.
They're in development,
can't drop any hints yet
but messaged some people
on my team this morning
as well as some outside
partners that I'm working with
that I'm pretty pumped to
see how things turn out.
Working on another
potential book talking about
the top 10 rules,
condensing them into the 50
top 10 rules from 50 different people.
Buy that book, you want to see that book?
We're getting some requests for that book,
it's taken 50 of the most
popular entrepreneurs
that I have on the channel,
condensing down their
top 10 rules into a book.
Where am I going, got to go to breakfast.
What else, hiring
somebody new for trying to
dance salsa, so just
going through applicants
and talking with Alex about
who we're going to hire.
So it's a fun process,
and just checking in with
my team and catching up on things.
It's amazing what you can
do when you wake up early
and you're willing to be
productive before anybody
else is awake.
So I'm lost, where am I going?
Oh it's over there,
breakfast is over there.
That's it, another exciting
day here at Climber Con.
I'm going to breakfast and
then a couple other sessions
that are happening.
I managed to upgrade
my ticket on American,
at least a second flight
from Dallas back to Toronto.
So I'm pretty pumped about that.
Last leg, I'm excited,
get to see Nina tomorrow,
get to see Temo, got a hair
cut, I'm pumped for that,
and let's go eat!
Hope you guys are having an amazing day.
I guess when you watch
this it'll be weekend.
I hope you have an amazing weekend.
(gentle music)
I'm the first one for breakfast, alright.
I get the best seat and the best food.
Got decisions to make,
where am I going to sit?
(chuckling)
so breakfast got filled up as you can see.
But I forgot my badge,
got to go back to my room,
get my badge, and then head
off to the first session.
So the first session today
is about how to continue
finding the love in your
channel, something like that.
I got here early.
So I can get the plug so
I can bring my laptop,
plug in, charge up my devices and stuff.
I am the first one here.
It's a day of being the
first of everything.
That's what happens when you get up early,
go crush it, guys.
(gentle music)
They're handing out emoji gumballs.
Nina's going to love these,
got to save them for her.
It's sweet.
I missed ice cream again today, Charlie!
- What's up every body?
- Charisma on Command,
Charisma on Command,
go check out his channel.
We got ice cream, the toppings,
but I missed ice cream.
I'm very sad.
He's into big escape rooms,
we might do that tonight,
Seven o'clock?
- Seven o'clock.
- Might do that, go check
out his Kevin Hart video
on Charisma, what's it called, Kevin Hart?
- Kevin Hart, three story telling secrets,
or something like that, story telling.
- It's really good, check it out.
So I forget where I
left off with you guys,
it's been crazy, it's been meeting after
meeting after meeting.
And going to go back to
the room to chill for a bit
and then at seven we're
going to do escape room.
Charlie apparently is
a huge escape room buff
and they have one here.
So we booked a time at seven,
so we're going to meet up
and head off over to there.
Got to get back and say
hi to Nina, spend a little
time with the wife, super important.
And then tomorrow morning,
take off for Toronto.
I'm meeting up with a new
friend, we're going to share
an Uber, do some chatting,
he does kids programming,
how to learn Spanish.
And then fly home.
I managed to upgrade my
ticket on the second flight
but on the first one I'm flying coach.
Hopefully not a middle seat, we'll see.
Alright we got Nina, woo!
I called Nina first but she wasn't home,
she was cleaning the carpet,
so I hopped in the shower.
- I was not available,
I was just cleaning,
just washing the carpets.
- [Vlogger] The carpets
are more important than me,
but the carpets are clean and
now she can talk to me, woo!
So we're just chatting while
I pack up and I'm going to
head off soon to get to the
escape room with Charlie.
What do you want to say Nina?
- Have fun, be good!
- [Vlogger] Be good, don't get
trapped in the escape room.
(laughing)
Make it out in time to leave
at 4:45 tomorrow morning
to get to the airport.
- And to see me!
- [Vlogger] To come home to see Nina.
- And believe!
- [Vlogger] And believe!
(gentle music)
Alright we made it,
escape room, Palm Springs.
First challenge, we'll
see hwo we do, Charlie the
escape room master, we'll see how it is.
I'm not allowed to film so
I'm going to stop right here.
Alright we made it, we
won the hardest room.
Had like a 19% success rate.
I did not contribute much to the team,
but we still won.
We had eight minutes left and made it out.
It's scary, it's very scary.
- It is kind of scary.
- Thomas looks decent
though, but look at the eyes.
- Decent if I'm like
the next serial killer
horror movie person.
- [Vlogger] That's scary.
- Charlie look at yourself in this.
- [Vlogger] Jessica and
Charile Hart carried the team.
You want these guys on your team.
The next Amazing Race
power couple right here.
- There we go.
(laughing)
- We're going to grab some
dinner, deciding on where to go.
Going to grab a bite to
eat with the new fam.
Probably going to get a pizza, we'll see.
Buffalo mozarella pizza,
what do you got Jessica?
You got food in your mouth.
- That was a trick question,
you had food in your mouth.
- [Vlogger] Charlie's got some salmon.
- Salmon, salmon and green beans.
- [Vlogger] And Thomas
has some, what do you got?
- Caviar pizza, $10,000.
Hashtag Lil Bow Wow.
(laughing)
- So that went way later than expected,
it's almost 12:30 am, I
got to wake up at 4:45
to catch my flight, but
we had a really good
conversation, I guess
that's what happens when you
get engrossed in good conversations.
So I'm excited to catch
a couple hours sleep,
get on the plane, go home, see the wife,
and it's been a blast.
I might do this again,
maybe a different conference, we'll see.
I was on the fence, but I'm glad I came.
Got some good results from
it, good conversations,
good people, ate dinner,
might just do it again.
We'll see, have a good night everyone.
(gentle music)
Good morning, good morning, good morning.
It is morning.
Looks the same as how
I shot last night on my
way to bed, huh?
Just past five o'clock, I'm
going to head to the airport,
coming back to Toronto,
I'm supposed to meet up
with another fellow YouTuber,
Basho, who does kids'
Spanish, French and
Chinese lessons I think,
teaching kids those languages.
So he's leaving at the
same time so we'd share an
Uber, have a chat in
the car, and head out.
I think there he is, hey, it's Basho!
- What's up man?
- You ready to go?
Alright, let's do it.
(gentle music)
I'm in the airport, I'm in the airport,
I got my ticket.
I'm excited for my coffee,
and maybe a little sleep,
but getting there.
Two all gates, yeah.
I love this airport.
It's tiny, people are friendly,
get in and out quickly.
And it's all open air
outdoor, it's beautiful.
Something's in Palm Springs, coming back.
This looks new, toasted
coconut, I think I'm going to
try one of those.
So I asked the barista if
the iced coconut cold brew
was sweet or not, I didn't
know if I needed to add
sugar or not, and she's
like "it's not very good."
Alright, "it's not very
good," I don't trust a barista
to make my drink who thinks
that this drink is not very
good, so instead caramel
machiato, Nina would approve,
it's her favorite.
Yummy, got like 20
minutes before my flight.
So head to the bathroom,
see if we can get online,
just Instagram, answer some
emails, check in with Nina,
and fly home!
(gentle music)
So looks like my flight
there, Toronto, American 1:10
got delayed to 1:45.
Got to get to gate C4.
Alright so it got delayed,
only by like 35 minutes,
25 minutes, 35 minutes, it's
not the end of the world.
I'm in Dallas and never been to Dallas.
I have a lot of fans from
Dallas, a lot of people
bought the book from Dallas.
A lot of people I know are
in Dallas, my agent's in
Dallas, I got to make a stop in Dallas.
If you're from Dallas
and want me to come by,
spend longer than two and
a half hours, let me know.
I have to find my gate and let Nina know
that I'm going to be late.
(gentle music)
So I'm pretty sure I'm going
to get some food on the plane.
Boarding in about 45 minutes,
but decided to stop off
and get a bold kale green smoothie.
Mm, not bad.
It was green kale smoothie
or McDonald's or pizza.
I'm like you know what,
I've had enough junk
this weekend, got to get
back to being healthy.
Not that this is insanely healthy,
but better than McDonald's.
(gentle music)
Alright I landed, decent
flight, little bit late
to get off.
And I haven't got put in a
circle before landing here,
it's always something
on the way back, I feel.
But it was nice to get the
upgrade and going to meet Nina
out side and go get Hayden,
relax and get some sleep
tonight after that four hours.
And that's it, thank you guys...
Thank you guys for joining me,
let me know what you think.
Let me know where I should go next.
Do you do conferences, I want to know.
If you do conferences, what
strategies did you learn
from conferences, put
in the comments below.
I'm curious to find out.
Hope you guys had a great weekend.
Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.